sie sind die männer für die besonders
schweren fällen
die kommissare silbern bormann und till
flat vom kriminaldauerdienst in hannover
[Musik]
er mit klavier aus einem kriminalfilm
ekd.de erlebt die dunkle seite der
menschheit
zum und morgen sind sie zur stelle der
bereitschaftsdienst der können
hannover ist jederzeit abrufbereit
sieben tage lieber bleiben wir im
kleinen leichnam vollständig
[Musik]
rund 11.500 straftaten werden jedes jahr
in hannover begann viel arbeit für die
kommissare vom kriminaldauerdienst
nicht immer ist klar was passiert
die kommissare entscheidenden treffen
die wohnungstür verschlossen
die tochter und am 2 hat die wohnungstür
aufschließen könne wenn der verdacht
einer straftat besteht sind die banken
von kdd die ersten wort was sie erwartet
[Musik]
mannschaft
montag dienstbeginn die woche startet
mit einem tragischen einsatz ein
arbeitsunfall auf einer baustelle nur
fünf kilometer von der wache entfernt
das todesopfer ist noch nicht gewonnen
da gab's arbeitsunfalls jemand gehört
steigleiter gefallen von der hebebühne
und er ist jetzt leider verstorben
unsere aufgabe besteht jetzt darin dass
wir mit den zeugen des vorfalls sprechen
und dann in einen objektiven gefunden
das gibt schreiben die gegebenheiten
machen eine kriminalpolizeiliche
leidenschaft
deswegen sei man schon von
entsprechend offen sei
solange die todesursache noch nicht
eindeutig geklärt ist muss polizei und
bekommt man alle tausende gehen die
arbeiter auf der baustelle stehen unter
schock vor wenigen minuten ist einer von
ihnen ums leben gekommen was ist hier
passiert meine kamera zu dokumentieren
was hier passiert ist und mein
diktiergerät damit ich gleich darauf
sprechen können
wie das aussieht beschreibung der
objektiven danach die leichenschau nur
diktiergerät brüsseler vier stunden über
das war zwar ein kurzer
darunter gefallen
ach ja ok besonders tragisch der tote
ist es 20 jahre alt ein schlosser
geselle weißt du was hier gemacht haben
nach oben
so nicht
aber ob er jetzt von einem steigleiter
unter luft flogen ist davon dass selbst
das kannst du besser
weil er alleine hier unterwegs
acht meter ist der in die tiefe gestürzt
und vermutlich mit dem kopf auf den
beton geschlagen seine kollegen
leisteten noch erste hilfe vergeblich
wir haben das hier unter seinen kopf
gelegt und dann haben die das darum und
da haben wir ja schon gemerkt hast die
ganze rechte hälfte und der der war
sofort tot na das ist ja mal gar nix
mehr
hat der junge mann das gleichgewicht
verloren warum war er auf der
arbeitsbühne nicht gesichert
polizeioberkommissar der ruf litt
befragt die anderen bauarbeiter wer hat
schuld
zu geben mit dem versprechen könnte
dafür diese sicherung zuständig wäre
michaelis leiter der baustelle und hat
zusammen mit anderen kollegen erste
hilfe geleistet was genau passiert ist
weiß er nicht wir haben das knall gehört
hatten da ist irgendein gleich vom dach
gefallen oder und kam schon ein kollege
da ist jemand runter gefallen und wenn
ich höre jemand ich weiß aus den kopf
dass das dach zirka acht meter hoch ist
wird sofort ein notruf
abgesetzt
nach der aufnahme des möglichen tatorts
muss silvan bormann die gesetzlich
vorgeschriebene leichenschau durchführen
aus beiden nasenöffnungen
läuft blute punkte zeile also wenn ich
jetzt sagen weil das mir das nichts
ausmacht und würde ich glaube ich lügen
das geht natürlich einem schulnahen auch
wenn das jemand ist der sehr junges oder
im gleichen alter ist nichtsdestotrotz
gehört zum job dazu und banken die man
muss hier machen
[Musik]
entkleiden den leichnam vollständig um
dann die kriminalpolizei vielleicht
schon durchzuführen
alles deutet auf einen tragischen unfall
hin kommissar ruf lebt macht die
dokumente für die angehörigen des toten
fertig zum einen einen überführungs
auftrag
und zum anderen eine stewardess
ermittlungs sache die todesermittlungen
sache und wird sagen den angehörigen
nicht übergeben werden jetzt durch die
polizei dann von dem werden
der traurigen
abnehmen
der mann könnte von der hebebühne auf
das dach geklettert seien und ist dann
vermutlich abgerutscht durfte er alleine
dort arbeiten ich tippe mal dieses
wellblech was hier so quer liegt das
muss ja irgendwie da hingelegt haben und
besser abgestützt sind praktisch herr
zwei ganz normal mitarbeiter und der
permanenten augen ja wenn er ist
auszubildender ist das noch mal eine
andere hausnummer du kannst du ja nicht
hier einfach machen lassen
und wenn er jetzt sagt hier der hat
sowieso immer das gemacht was er heute
ist er trotzdem in der pflicht zu sagen
du trägst aber anständige arbeitsschuhe
du trägst ein geschirr
da ist auch blut drin so dass auch von
außen blutig aber
ob er den trägt oder nicht das macht bei
der frau nichts los die bestatter sind
daran transportieren die leichname
[Musik]
die späteren ermittlungen ergeben dass
unternehmen trifft keine schuld es
handelt sich um einen tragischen unfall
für baumann und flat ist der fall damit
hier abgeschlossen mehr als 100 tote
sehen die beiden pro jahr deswegen geld
ganz klar was im dienst passiert bleibt
[Musik]
wenn ich feierabend haben danach hat und
dann habe ich feierabend und freizeit
und dann geht es erst wieder los
vielleicht zum dienst kommen
zum ausgleich geht will beim bau man
gerne angeln dass er mal bei der polizei
die banken schon als kleine
ich würde man bei frankfurt und dann
habe ich ein brennendes ausgesehen die
wohnung und da stand dann
kriminalbeamter vor dem haus was der
gewandtheit und
was kann ich irgendwie war der s p
future um
totschlag es gibt nichts was nicht schon
gesehen hat manchmal muss ja auch dinge
tun die viele menschen nicht tun würden
an seinen ersten einsatz erinnert er
sich noch genau
die verstorbene
lag etwas länger in der wohnung und es
mussten noch fingerabdrücke genommen
werden die vier waren aber schon verwest
so dass wir die ganzen hände ab trennen
mussten das war so sehr dass ich gar
nicht
viel darüber nachdenken konnte wenn man
dann mit zwei händen im auto unfälle
zurück fährt denkbar ist okay was macht
man hier eigentlich gerade
wie alle kollegen fürchtet er vor allem
eines irgendwann nichts mehr zu
empfinden aber davon ist silbern bormann
noch sehr weit entfernt
hannover gut 500.000 einwohner pro jahr
werden etwa 70.000 200 straftaten
gemeldet das macht fast 100 am tag noch
2017 war hannover laut statistik die
zweit gefährlichste stadt in deutschland
der nächste tag auf die beamten kommt
eine zwölf stunden schicht zu die dienst
war für wird immer mitgenommen denn die
arbeit an frischen tatorten risiken zu
dienstbeginn rüsten wir uns mit unseren
einsatzmitteln auf das ist zum einen
unsere dienstwaffe
die handschellen ein ersatz magazin die
taschenlampe und ein pfefferspray
[Musik]
hanns schumacher der erste einsatz
bildet sie in ein mehrfamilienhaus wie
lange es der mann schon tot darum ist er
gestorben fragen denen die kommissarin
nachgehen müssen und dann heute mehr
oder weniger fortschritte bei der heute
geburtstag ausgerufen wird dem besucher
die feuerwehr hat die tür geöffnet und
fand in 74 jährigen neben seiner
badewanne bormann und rufle teilen sich
auf um hinweise darauf zu finden was
hier passiert ist wir gucken nach
medikamenten jetzt zu sich genommen hat
nach arztbriefen nach dem hausarzt
anzeichen dafür zu finden dass er eines
natürlichen todes gestorben ist als
erstes müssen die beamten ausschließen
dass ein täter die wohnung betreten
haben könnten beginnen bei objektiven
befund der sie in der regel je nach
sachverhalt aber in der regel daran
orientiert wie sind die schlüsselstelle
der türen insbesondere wenn man einen
toten aufgefunden hat und zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt nicht sagen kann woran er
verstorben ist weiterhin ist links
daneben der briefkasten
eingefasst
ist dann beispielsweise darum geht eine
tageszeitung hier auch zu finden die
wird uns natürlich eindeutig der hinweis
liefern woher zu vielleicht an dem tag
ins nichts heraus gefischt die letzte
tageszeitung befindet sich noch in der
wohnung datiert auf den ersten oktober
2020 der mann ist zu diesem zeitpunkt
schon mehr als zwei wochen tot
kommissar ruf welt übernimmt die
gesetzlich vorgeschriebene leichenschau
zwischen dem waschbecken
der badewanne und der waschmaschine wird
hier ein augenscheinlichen männlicher
leichnam in shrek nach rechts sitzender
position
vor von den punkt neue zeile
die wohnung liefert erste hinweise auf
die mögliche todesursache
zwischen alkohol und zigaretten findet
kommissar mit tabletten gegen
bluthochdruck und herzrhythmusstörungen
an der rechten wand besteht ein esstisch
platziert auf dem diverse
medikamentenschachteln sowie minister
festgestellt werden können der
verstorbene musste starke raucher
gewesen sein das sind so anhaltspunkte
die halt für uns auch interessant sind
er hat gerne wein getrunken geraucht
hatte diverse vorerkrankungen vieles
deutet auf einen natürlichen tod auch
weil die wohnung von innen verschlossen
waren hier in dem fall können wir ja
ausschließen dass ein täter die wohnung
verlassen hat weil die wohnungstür war
verschlossen und selbst die tochter mit
einem zweitschlüssel hat die wohnungstür
aufschließen können weil der schlüssel
von den stecker der fall ist damit für
die beiden abgeschlossen die
todesursache so wird es später
festgestellt werden herz kreislauf
versagen
tote
und einer mit todesfolgen deutschen
polieren doch es wird nicht ihr letzter
einsatz des tages sein
es ist kurz nach mitternacht der nächste
notruf kommt etwas außerhalb von
hannover einbruch in ein einfamilienhaus
die täter haben anscheinend versucht den
tresor im keller mit einem
winkelschleifer zu öffnen im ganzen haus
riecht es verbrannt der einbruch kann
also noch nicht lange her sein kollegen
kollegen kollegen da ist dass das hier
noch so heiß trägt und so lasst uns mal
das komplette haus noch durchsuchen wir
gehen jetzt draußen gibt suchen das haus
mal ganz kurz ja nicht dass der täter
sich jetzt hier noch versteckt hält dass
fremde die eigenen vier wände betreten
ist für viele hausbesitzer ein
horrorszenario
aber dass die männer auch noch hier sein
könnten ist für die hausbewohnerin
endgültig zu viel
also man kann gar nicht mehr das haus
verlassen
die täter sind weg zusammen mit
handtaschen schmuck silberbesteck
zigarren und bargeld die beute ist
wahrscheinlich mehrere tausend euro wert
bormann vermutet die einbrecher sind
über den balkon eingestiegen
hier sieht man die hebelmarken an den
holzrahmen der balkontür
oder das ist
der handschuh abdruck tour sieht man an
den
gewählten linien eines oben rein hat den
balken reck gemacht und die haben das
dann von außen aufgeschoben nachdem er
das geöffnet hat kommissar bauermann ist
sich sicher hier waren profis am werk
fast 90.000 mal wurde im vergangenen
jahr in deutschland eingebrochen nur ein
sechstel davon wird aufgeklärt keine
rosigen aussichten für die hausbesitzer
sorgen ganz ganz mieses gefühl gewesen
da war dass seine leute in hirnschäden
schlafzimmer zum beispiel genommen und
richtig freude kommt nochmal das ist um
so die die dating lesung im kopf mit dem
gesetz macht möchte diese so dass jetzt
mehr leute wissen dass dann selbst drin
ist und die wissen auch wie widerstands
folge ist dann würde nicht die
einbrecher müssen in eile geflohen sein
sie haben nämlich im keller etwas liegen
lassen
jetzt
an die hier versucht den tresor
aufzuflexen
dabei haben sie sich
nicht zur hilfe genommen das haben sie
aber anscheinend vergessen aber dass
sich ja jetzt hier im original
weil wir da vielleicht ein paar
dna-spuren daran haben
wer so gezielt vorgeht der war
vielleicht schon einmal im haus born und
ruf vermuten dass die einbrecher sich
auskannten zufälligerweise hatte das
ehepaar heute vormittag besuch von einer
klempner firma einen ermittlungsansatz
für die kollegen sie sagen ja sie
vertrauen im klemmt bei den canon seit
20 jahren der kommt aber vielleicht mit
neuen mitarbeitern auszubildenden dass
man den mal anruft und fragt wer waren
das eigentlich noch und dann kann man
die die kollegen des klempners mal
überprüfen und mal gucken was ist aus
einem clubs ansatz weil es schon
häufiger vorkommen ist die weiteren
ermittlungen wird nun eine andere
dienststelle übernehmen bormann und ruft
müssen weiter
nächste einsatz wartet schon
ein raubüberfall in einer kneipe der
nächste einsatzort ist ein vereinsheim
eine gruppe jugendlicher soll die
gaststätte überfallen die kasse geraubt
und den wird mit einer flasche verletzt
haben wurde dann wurden einfach getreten
von allen personen so wie er das sagt
aber
er kann die nur den haupttäter so
einigermaßen geschrieben vormann
inspiziert den tatort
[Musik]
hier habe ich zum einen meine schwarze
folie zu sichern von schuhabdruck spuren
ein bisschen was an werkzeug meine
serien für fingerabdrücke das ist
us-bürger und pinsel
dann meinen den sicherungs werkzeug denn
ein tatort ohne spuren ist sehr sehr
was wir hier jetzt hätten werden zum
einen
fingerabdruck auf der zerbrochenen
flasche wo ich so mal so ein bisschen
kuscheln
okay es war so als ob ich das sehe die
ist jetzt nach und da tatsächlich sieht
man hinter den finger habt ist ein
mögliche dna spur weil die täter die
flasche mitgebracht haben und vielleicht
vorher daraus getrunken haben deswegen
nehme ich davon jetzt eine dna spur
das opfer ist der betreiber der
gaststätte er wirkt auf die beamten
stark alkoholisiert er schildert den
tathergang so
[Musik]
doch ohne aussagen von zeugen ist es
schwer nachzuvollziehen ob es sich
wirklich so zugetragen hat eine
ungereimtheit ist dass der wirt
keinerlei verletzungen hat obwohl er
eine flasche von den angreifern
abbekommen haben soll
[Applaus]
sollte er wird die tat erfunden haben um
die 300 euro von der versicherung zu
bekommen könnte es teuer für ihn werden
das vortäuschen einer straftat kann eine
geldstrafe oder sogar eine
freiheitsstrafe von bis zu drei jahren
einbringen der kollege hat denn jetzt
eingehend belehrt
na ja dasselbe nochmal überhaupt was ich
hier genau abgespielt hat werden erst
die weiteren ermittlungen in den
nächsten tagen zeigen wir fangen
israelin stelle legen das ganze in
unserem system an diktieren zu ende und
dann endlich feierabend machte auf
manchmal mache ich
eine ganz normale schicht geboren am 14
nüchterne bilanz des
kriminaloberkommissar ein toter ein
einbruch umgebracht
ab einem gewissen punkt weiß man einfach
was einen erwartet wenn man eine gewisse
zeit hier im café gearbeitet hat es ist
so dass ich weiß wie eine leichte nach
vier wochen aussieht wenn ich dann einen
einsatz bekommen im sommer wo die leiche
vier wochen noch nicht da weiß ich
worauf ich mich einlasse wir nicht dahin
fahren was mich erwartet
[Musik]
endlich waren für die kommissare nach
einer mütze schlaf steht morgen die
nächste schicht aber das böse nimmt sich
hier sicher keine pause
[Musik]
du kommst wird uns mit